make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it's been a little while since
we did a video on characters that are
like too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right do powerful for
the MCU and I thought it'd be kind of
cool to jump back into this series again
or at least test the waters to see if
people care and in this video we're
gonna be covering the Man GOG now here's
the thing man GOG is this ridiculously
powerful character in Marvel Comics and
here's the funny thing to understand
here man GOG is largely an Asgardian
character you don't really see man GOG
face off against like The Incredible
Hulk or somebody like that does it
really work that way and the reason why
is because man GOG has a vendetta
against Asgard itself and the funny
thing is if they chose to put Magog in
the MCU they could actually do it given
the existing history of Asgard all that
kind of stuff so on the clock doc we
don't know a whole lot of history about
the character but we don't know a whole
lot of history in terms of how he became
who we became all we know is what we
were told in Thor number 154 when he
first appeared and it was basically this
idea that man God represents the total
rage of some race that was killed by
Odin at some point in time and that's it
that's really all we get we don't really
have a definitive origin now if Marvel
is eventually going to put him in the
MCU then you will see an origin story
for him somewhere along a line right
otherwise there'd be no reason to
introduce an origin right it wouldn't it
wouldn't really make any sense and so
that's when you'd most likely know he
was gonna make an appearance in the MCU
either that or it's just part of like
Donnie Cates Thor run right so it might
not mean anything at all outside of the
fact that Donnie Cates is gonna do
something with him but man GOG is this
foe who is virtually unstoppable that's
really kind of what he represents he's
almost like The Incredible Hulk to the
imp degree in the sense that like when
the Hulk is is super pissed off right
he's almost unbeatable but unlike the
Incredible Hulk Man GOG is like zero to
60 right I mean it's one of these things
where he's just that powerful
automatically it takes incredible whole
time to build up to that level of
strength like we saw that happen in
phases during greg packs run right you
had the Incredible Hulk who became like
The Incredible Hulk on planets a car he
was really powerful then he became world
breaker Hulk during the World War Hulk
storyline and then he became heart of
the monster hole right it just kind of
went up in different levels as the story
went on and his events as events
transpired but the idea here is that man
GOG is the only being that I'm aware of
in all of Marvel Comics that Odin was
actually afraid of and that really spoke
volumes right because the idea was that
when he originally popped up he was
accidentally awoken by a rock troll and
he basically started going on a warpath
throughout Asgard and end up taking like
the combined forces of all the
Asgardians to basically try to bring
them to a standstill and lock it back up
again
because the truth is that man GOG under
traditional means cannot truly be killed
so long as there's rage and anger out
there in the world man God will always
exist really just in the universe man
God will always exist right he feeds off
that inherent inherit rage and inherent
anger and that's what makes him so
powerful as well this is why he's just
kind of like this this unstoppable
immutable force is because in the more
recent instances of Marvel Comics for
example during the end of Jason Aaron's
run on Thor with Jane Foster Jane Foster
was able to hold off man God by
basically trapping him in the Sun for a
period of time and that was basically it
but he's just coming he was there in the
Sun as far as we're aware and he's still
there but he cannot actually be
destroyed he'll end up coming back and
so when you talk about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what you have here is
this place as we've talked about so many
times before where things are more
rooted and things are more tangible and
the characters are far less powerful
than they normally really are but even
if we scaled man god for that level of
power he would still be enough to
overpower everybody there are a few
caveats to this and this is one of the
important things that really go into the
nature of his character the first
question people will ask here is
couldn't man God defeat Thanos even with
the comic book version of Thanos if
we're talking about like blow-for-blow
brute strength didn't yeah he would he'd
be able to overpower Thanos quite
readily and take him out but what Fanus
lacks in physical strength in comparison
to man GOG he makes up for in
intelligence technology various
abilities the fact that he is for the
most part immortal because he's just
kind of banned from the realm of
mistress death but even if we remove
that and we say that he is mortal and he
can die he'll find a way to defeat man
GOG right like that battle won't go on
forever
right like ultimately Thanos would end
up finding a way to win because he's
just more intelligent than man God is
but the funny thing is that man God is
not just brute strength right we're
talking about a guy who can shape-shift
right so there was one point in time
when he duplicated the form of Odin so
like we know that he can do things like
that right he's just he's ultra powerful
in that way but with regards to that to
the idea of putting him in the MCU you
could get away with this right because
if in the comics man God represents this
sum total of all the rage of a
particular race that was wiped out by
Odin we know from Thor Ragnarok that
hella was the daughter of Odin that we
never knew about and then he and her had
gone on a crusade to like wipe out
various races for the purpose of
securing the throne of Asgard now in the
comics it was totally different right
Halle was just a chick who was there and
she was the ruler of hell and that was
basically it aside
Matt and her attempts to like take out
Odin and usurp the throne of Asgard she
never really had any involvement with
him she's certainly not a relative of
his she's the daughter of Loki but
that's really all you have in relation
so I guess she's really like the
grandfather she's the granddaughter of
Odin if you want to look at it that way
but the fact remains here that's given
the history of the MCU the way the Thor
Ragnarok played out the fact that hella
was instrumental and basically bringing
down all these other races you could
throw man Gaga in there you could just
say one of these races that were
destroyed by Asgard basically channeled
using using mystical means or sorcery or
what-have-you channeled all their hatred
and all their rage into creating a
singular being it was powerful enough to
basically get their revenge on Odin
right because they knew that their fate
was sealed there's no way they would
survive and man God serves that purpose
of just trying to constantly get revenge
on on Odin by like destroying him and
all the other ass Guardians and
instilling this idea that like Odin is
afraid of him now at this point Odin is
gone so you would just have Thor left to
contend with him and that's where things
get kind of murky because during the
events of Thor disassembled or Thor
Ragnarok if that's what you want to call
it during the events of that particular
comic book Thor was able to destroy man
God but that wasn't exceptionally
powerful for that was Thor with the Thor
force also imbued with the Norn stone
way more powerful than Odin was and he
was on a whole nother
esalaam right the level he possessed of
the power he possessed would have been
enough to probably tank most cosmic
entities that were out there right if
not all the ones within any one
particular universe and so when you're
talking about that level of power then
yeah he was able to basically wave his
hand and destroy man Gog and that was
basically it at the same time despite
all the rage and all all those abilities
that man God has if you're able to
disrupt his ability to tap into his rage
right so someone who's a sufficiently
powerful telepath or somebody like that
they can basically D power man GOG right
they could basically remove that element
from him at the same time if you have
something like the Infinity Gauntlet man
gog is nothing more than just matter
that's all he is right so using
something like the Infinity Gauntlet
that's an obvious win right you just
using Infinity Gauntlet destroy him that
kind of a thing so there are tools that
exist inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as a means to basically destroy
the man gun but as it stands right now
with regards to the various heroes who
were out there not a chance no one in
the MCU
would be able to go toe-to-toe with man
God the only person that could really
achieve a level of power in order to do
that would likely be the Incredible Hulk
but it wouldn't really be Thor I thought
where the Thor force is powerful but it
was all he could do to hold his own
like like he's powerful but you know
against like against someone likes a
nose wielding the infinities Infinity
Gauntlet Thor Thor with the eighth with
a Thor force was not an immutable
indestructible being right he was just
super powerful but like with somebody
like the man god it's kind of hard to
gauge that we can go back to the example
of Thor using the Thor force the Norn
stones right but that's kind of a cheap
and that's what we might as well invoke
characters like the molecule man the
marquee of death or somebody along those
lines who can just show up snap their
fingers and the man gods dead gone but
for the sake of a more tangible
realistic MCU and so far I guess as
realistic as it can be you know in terms
of being superheroes and you know in the
real world ultimately man dog would
would stomp everyone right again the
only way that I could really see him
being defeated is if you ended up having
like the Incredible Hulk
basically being amped up to the to the
point of like world breaker hole right
and that's why having somebody like
Vanguard would be amazing we can say for
example that man god want to destroy all
the Asgardians and let's say that in the
aftermath of everything that's happened
with infinity war and Avengers in game
that what passes for Asgard currently
out on earth is truly rebuilt right like
the actual castle and everything is
rebuilt but it resides in Broxton
Oklahoma instead of you know out in the
middle of Norway or ever was and in the
MCU and so say that like man God somehow
arrives or wakes up or whatever the case
is and goes on the hunt for the
Asgardians and discovers that they're on
earth and then basically using his
mystical abilities teleports to earth
and then you know Thor's return from
guardians of the galaxy or what have you
and the two of them end up fighting all
right they say like this fight is its
massive as I'm calling in some of the
other superheroes is a pretty huge
crossover event and let's say they're
like Betty Betty Ross dies or something
like that what this would do is it could
lead to the leader Bruce Banner snapping
right the incredible whole persona
flipping its mind like like absolutely
losing its mind and then like snapping
in the world breaker Hulk at that point
mangog is dunzo right not a chance like
there's there's no way that man GOG
would ever say in a chance against World
Recor hole and if he did it would be an
even fight beyond that you go into heart
of the monster Hulk and that was a
version of The Incredible Hulk that was
able to like tear dimensions apart no
way that you would see man god be able
to go toe-to-toe against somebody like
part of the monster I don't see that
happening at all but I also don't really
see us getting heart of the monster Hulk
in the MCU because it's even for comic
books it was so far-fetched literally we
got that version of The Incredible Hulk
because Bruce Banner discovered a
wishing well so I don't really know but
I think that at the moment as it stands
right now in no way man God loses
he's just way too powerful for anybody
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe right
he would stomp pretty much everybody and
it wouldn't even be by a little bit
either so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here the comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]